Hallo, Sie sind mit dem Skype-Testservice verbunden. Nach dem Ton haben Sie die Möglichkeit, eine Nachricht zu hinterlassen, die Sie anschliessend abhören können. Also, hallo und herzlich willkommen zur Aufnahme von Podcast UFO 113. Herzlich willkommen zu 113. Das Technik-Setup steht auf wackeligem Bein, wir haben hier drei Mikrofone vor uns, zwei Lampops. In einem riesigen Raum sitzen wir in der Ecke zusammengefärcht, weil wir uns Kopfhörer teilen müssen. Naja, so reden wir mit der schlauesten Frau der Welt, Anna Frebel. Es hat sich hoffentlich gelohnt, diesen langen Aufwand. Wir mussten uns heute nicht auswieseln, da sind wir auch schon sehr stolz darauf. Momentan läuft die Skype-Anfrage. Hallo. Hello. Hello, this is Cologne calling. Ja, hallo. Ja, vielen Dank nochmal, tut es leid für letzte Woche, dass das nicht so ganz geklappt hat,
aber diesmal haben wir alle technischen Ressourcen zusammengesammelt und es sollte heute klappen.
Ja, sorry nochmal, dass es nicht funktioniert hat, aber es freut uns sehr, dass Sie zu Gast sind bei uns heute.
Für die Leute, die Frau Frebel nicht kennen, es ist eine Astrophysikerin,
die unfassbar früh schon eine der ältesten Sterne der Menschheit bekannt gefunden hat und jetzt am MIT eine Professur hat. Ist das korrekt? Genau. Ja, ja, ist genau richtig. Alles wunderbar. Also wir sind natürlich total Physik interessiert. Wir haben auch im Podcast schon viel von unserem Halbwissen immer bekannt gegeben. Also mich würde das mal interessieren, also sie suchen ja aktiv nach Sternen in unserer Galaxie und suchen, wie ich das verstanden habe, nach den ältesten Sternen. Und das machen Sie, indem Sie die eisenärmsten Sterne finden, richtig? Also Sie versuchen dann, je nachdem, was die Sterne so ab, sondern an Strahlung versuchen Sie dann, die ältesten Sternen zu finden, nach Erfahrungswerten, die Sie haben. Genau, da haben Sie sich ja gut vorbereitet. Ja, cool. Wir suchen also die allerältesten Sterne, die als zweite und dritte und vierte Generation von Sternen im Universum sich gebildet haben. Und die sind wahrscheinlich relativ massearm, oder da sind einige übrig geblieben, die sind relativ massearm, also weniger massereich als die Sonne, sprich sie wiegen weniger als die Sonne, sie waren auf Diät.
Und deswegen haben die eine ganz lange Lebenszeit. Die Lebenszeit ist so 15 bis 20 Milliarden Jahre und das Universum ist aber erst 13,8 Milliarden Jahre alt. Das heisst, die Dinger sind heute noch übrig. Und genau, wir nehmen dann also das Licht von diesem Stern oder von Kandidaten
erstmal mit einem Teleskop auf und dann lassen wir das Licht durch ein Prisma mehr oder weniger
laufen und dann nehmen wir ein sogenanntes Spektrum davon auf und das Spektrum verrät uns dann die
Zusammensetzung, die chemische Zusammensetzung des Sterns. Und da haben wir halt verschiedene Kriterien, was gut und was besser und was total schlecht ist. Und dementsprechend wird ausgesiebt. Okay, ganz kurz. Stefan hat sich wahnsinnig gut vorbereitet und hat sich sehr Physik interessiert. Ich habe nicht so wahnsinnig viel Ahnung. Und ich muss mal ganz kurz nachfragen, was bedeutet das denn, dass Sterne unterschiedlich alt sind? Ist denn das Universum nicht alles gleich alt? Das ist eine super Frage. Ne, ist nicht alles gleich alt. Ist es genauso, wenn man auf dem Marktplatz steht und da sind lauter Leute, die haben ja auch nicht alles gleiche Alter. Und genauso, wenn man jetzt also in den Himmel quasi schaut und was man da so blinken sieht, das hat auch nicht alles das gleiche Alter. Die meisten Stämme sind natürlich relativ jung, aber auch da gibt es noch viele Unterschiede und mit relativ jung, da meine ich so wie die Sonne, so nur 4,6 Milliarden Jahre alt. Das ist jung und frisch, aber ab und zu sind halt auch ein paar alte Sterne dabei, die sich in der Frühzeit des Universums gewählt haben. Also nochmal, um darauf zurückzukommen. Aber bilden sich jetzt noch Sterne? Ja, ja, klar. Bilden sich jetzt auch noch Sterne? Aber wie kommt denn das, also ich stelle mir genau, okay, aber es ist halt schwierig, sich vorzustellen, weil man stellt sich das All ja immer so als Riesenvakuum vor, wo mal so ein Partikel rumschwirrt irgendwie. Ja, ja, aber das ist eine wichtige Sache. Nee, das ist wirklich wie bei Leuten. Also es gibt eine Generation nach der anderen, und ich habe die Gene von meinen Eltern und meinen Grosseltern in mir, und genauso haben Sterne quasi die kosmischen Gene in sich, denn die sind aus einer Gaswolke entstanden, entstanden, die von den vorhergehenden Generationen von Sternen mit schweren Elementen angereichert wurde. Und wir suchen halt nur nach den Allerältesten und die Sonne ist nicht so alt und die ist aus einer Gaswolke entstanden, die schon von ganz, ganz vielen, wahrscheinlich Tausenden oder Tausenden von Sternen angereichert worden, dass sie aus so einer Gaswolke entstanden, die angereichert wurde. Und jetzt gerade sogar im Orionnebel bilden sich gerade kleine, süße Sternchen. Der Orionnebel ist im Sternbild Orion, den man ja im Winter immer schön sieht. Das sind diese drei Punkte nebeneinander. Genau, der Orionnebel ist in der Mitte von dem Schwert, das direkt unter dem Gürtel hängt. Also wenn man da mit dem Feldstecher mal guckt, dann sieht man sogar, dass dieser mittlere Stern da nicht wirklich eine scharfe Punktquelle ist, sondern so ein bisschen rosa verschwommenes Nebelchen und da bilden sich gerade Sternen. Sternbilder sind ein grosses Fragezeichen. Bei Sternbilder, also den Wagen gehe ich noch mit, der sieht aus wie ein Wagen, aber der Löwe, das sind drei Striche, das ist für mich kein Löwe. Aber Aurea ist ein tolles Sternbild, weil A kennen das viele Leute und B, da hat einiges zu bieten. Also da ist auch der linke Schulterstern, das ist zum Beispiel ein Überriese, ein roter, der wird irgendwann mal explodieren, also noch nicht morgen oder übermorgen, aber der ist so ganz am Ende seines Lebens angelangt und flickert da quasi nur noch. Und auch der Sirius, der so ein bisschen weiter links vom linken Fussstern entfernt ist, das ist der hellste Stern am nördlichen Sternenhimmel, und der ist auch ein ganz netter Stern. Also es lohnt sich schon ein klein bisschen, sich mit Orion zu beschäftigen, da lernt man gleich den ganzen Haufen Astronomie. Okay, gut, also das habe ich grob verstanden. Das heißt, man muss sich so vorstellen, es gab irgendwann den Urknall, da hat alles angefangen, und seitdem sammeln sich dann immer mal wieder Sterne, die dann wieder wieder explodieren oder dann sammeln sich wieder neue Klumpen an, wo dann wieder neue Planeten, neue Sterne draus werden, aber sie haben von Generationen gesprochen. Wie funktioniert das denn?
Naja, eins nach dem anderen.
Das impliziert, dass es irgendwie ein System gibt, nach dem das funktioniert.
Naja, man hat halt Glaswolke, da bildet sich irgendwie mal ein Stern draus, weil die Glaswolke ein bisschen zusammenklumpt aufgrund der Gravitation. Das ist die Kraft, die den Apfel fallen lässt. Und dieser Stern, oder meistens bilden sich mehrere Sterne, einzelne Sterne bilden sich eigentlich nicht so gerne. Und aus so einer Gruppe von Sternen explodieren halt die dicken Fetten, die richtig massereich sind, die so zehnmal mehr als die Sonne wiegen und noch mehr, die explodieren und schmeissen dann alle die schwereren Elemente, die in dem Innern zusammengekocht wurden, zwecks Energieerzeugung. Das wird halt in diese Gaswolke geschleudert und die kleinen Sterne, die aufgrund ihrer langen Lebensdauer, die bleiben da einfach hocken. Und dann ein bisschen weiter später, also ich komme ein bisschen auf die Bedingungen und so an,
aber so 100 Millionen Jahre später bildet sich dann halt aus dieser etwas angereicherten Gaswolke wieder irgendwelche Sterne.
Und dann spiralt sich das halt so voran.
Was man bei Ihnen auch immer lesen kann, und wenn man sich ein bisschen über sie informiert, glaube ich, schwingt immer mit, dass wir alle ja nur aus Sternenstaub bestehen quasi. Alle Elemente, die es in uns sind und so, sind ja quasi die Reste von Sternen. Also ich versuche das irgendwie nachzuvollziehen. Also Sterne betreiben die ganze Zeit so eine Kernfusion. Genau, genau. Wo Helium zum Beispiel und Wasserstoff sich verschmelzen und dann neue Elemente im Periodensystem ergeben. Da ist ja unten immer diese Ordnungszahl, das ist doch die Anzahl der Protonen, weiß ich nicht. und dann entstehen halt immer mehr
Elemente. Ist das richtig, bei alten Sternen
müsste man noch wahnsinnig viele Elemente haben,
weil das schon so lange fortgeschritten ist,
dieser Prozess? Naja, fast
richtig.
Also das Universum hat angefangen
nur mit Wasserstoff und Helium. Das ist
alles das, was der Urknall
geschafft hat. Dann
sind die ersten Sterne entstanden und die haben da ganz richtig im Inneren Kernfusion betrieben.
Und zwar wird Wasserstoff erstmal zu Helium verschmolzen, da kriegt man am meisten Energie raus und das machen die Sterne am längsten.
Und dann wird Helium zu Kohlenstoff weiter verschmolzen und Kohlenstoff zu Silizium und an anderen.
Also alles hin bis zu Eisen, also die ganzen oberen Elemente im Periodensystem. Und dann sind diese Sterne explodiert und all das, was da so fleissig zusammengeköchelt wurde, wurde halt in die Gaswolke da gesprüht. Aber natürlich nur ein ganz klein bisschen, weil das ja nur ein, zwei, drei Sterne waren, die das gemacht haben am Anfang. Und das, was wir gerade eben besprochen haben, dass dann aus dieser angereicherten Gaswolke da der nächste Stern entsteht, besteht er hauptsächlich natürlich wieder aus Wasserstoff und Helium, aber auch kleinsten, kleinsten Anteilen von diesen schweren Elementen wie Eisen.
Und genau das sind, also wir sprechen jetzt gerade von der zweiten Generation, an meinem Beispiel da, und das sind genau die Sterne, die wir suchen. Und die haben halt nur ganz wenig, weil dieser Prozess der Elementproduktion, der Anreicherung der Gaswolken um die Sterne rum und dann die nachfolgende Bildung von Sternen, das ist ein Prozess, der wie so ein Schneeballprinzip bis heute vorangeht und auch noch in der Zukunft weitergeht. Also irgendwann haben wir nur noch Eisen im Universum, obwohl das auch noch ziemlich lange dauert.
Aber das ist genau der Grund. Also die Masse, die Menge aller Elemente, die schwerer als Wasser, Schau und Helium sind, die steigt an mit der Zeit. Und wir suchen uns einfach die Sterne, die ganz wenig haben, weil das bedeutet dann, die müssen ganz am Anfang sich gebildet haben.
Okay. Und ist das ein Prozess, der irgendwo ein notwendiges Ende hat, wo dann einfach Schluss ist? Genau, Eisen. Also das, was ich gerade schon so im Witzchen angedeutet hatte. Also durch Fusion kann man nichts erzeugen, was schwerer als Eisen ist. Da ist einfach Schluss aus atomphysikalischen Gründen. Wir haben natürlich die ganzen Elemente, die schwerer sind als Eisen, da können Sie mich gleich noch zu fragen. Aber Sterne werden irgendwann hauptsächlich aus Gas bestehen, was nicht mehr Wasserstoff und Helium ist, weil alles schon konvertiert wurde und transformiert wurde in schwerere Elemente. Und dann kriegen die irgendwann auch gar nicht mehr genug Energie daraus, nur noch ein bisschen. Und das wird eine interessante Zeit werden, aber das dauert noch ein paar Trillionen Jahre, würde ich sagen. Und wie sähe das dann konkret aus? Also dann werden alle Sonnen oder alle Sterne dann ausgebrannt? Ja, die könnten, die, es würden einfach keine Sterne mehr entstehen, weil die Definition von einem Stern, die wir im Moment haben, ist, dass Kernfusion im Innern betrieben wird, damit der Stern überhaupt leuchten kann. Wenn man, wenn man nicht mehr genug Kernfusion betreiben kann, weil man nicht genug Energie aus diesen schwereren Kernen rauskriegt, dann kann man auch nichts zünden, dann kann man nichts leuchten und dann haben wir einfach nur noch Gasklumpen im Universum und es wird irgendwie dunkel. Etwas traurig, aber naja. Und was passiert dann? Ist dann einfach Schluss? Dann ist Schluss, ja, dann ist aus dem Haus. Macht Ihnen das Angst? Macht Ihnen was Angst? Weil ich hab manchmal abends liege im Bett und denke, wir rasen gerade auf so einem kleinen Felsbrocken, einfach so mit unverstellbarer Geschwindigkeit durchs All und überall lauern Gefahren, überall lauert der nächste Meteor, der in uns reinkracht einfach. Macht Ihnen sowas Angst oder ist es eher so, je mehr Sie wissen und erschliessen über das Universum, desto mehr sind Sie beruhigt oder desto mehr macht es Ihnen Angst?
Naja, ich habe natürlich da eine pragmatische Angehensweise. Angst macht es mir nicht, weil es natürlich tatsächlich ungelogen noch ein paar Trillionen Jahre dauern wird, bevor das passiert. Wie weit sind wir denn auf dem Weg? Also wenn jetzt Urknall null ist und dieser Punkt, an dem es keine Fusion gibt, ist 100. Jetzt sind wir bei zwei Prozent.
Bei zwei Prozent.
Wir haben erst bei zwei Prozent.
Bei zwei Prozent. Wir haben erst mal zwei Prozent des ganzen Universums hinter uns. Ja, also von der Zeit her. Das zieht sich aber auch. Also das wird dann noch ein bisschen schneller gehen und so, aber es ist noch jede Menge Zeit und wir werden auch andere astronomische Probleme vorher haben. Der rote Riese. Nämlich die Sonne wird sich in ein paar Milliarden Jahren ja zu einem roten Riesenstern aufblähen und alle Planeten, alle inneren Planeten erst mal quasi auffressen. Also ja, man muss das alles in Relation sehen. Wie Einstein schon sagte, alles ist relativ. Der Mann wahrscheinlich schlecht, oder? Ja, den hätte ich gerne mal getroffen. Sie rechnen da ja in unfassbare Vergangenheiten zurück. Wie verlässlich sind denn solche Berechnungen oder wie schwierig ist das? Weil ich denke mir immer so, das ist ja ein unglaublich komplexes System. Alle verschiedenen Himmelskörper haben ja unterschiedliche Gravitationen aufeinander irgendwie. Und je weiter man zurückrechnet, desto weniger verlässlich ist es doch. Oder wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen Planeten nicht beachtet hat, der einmal irgendwie quer durchgeflogen ist. Also ich stelle mir das ein bisschen vor wie Wetter, wo alles sich gegenseitig bedingt. Und jetzt, wir haben ja keine Chance, das Wetter von in ein paar Tagen wirklich vernünftig zu berechnen, geschweige denn rückwärts. Warum kann man das denn beim Universum dann so präzise, in so einer unfassbaren Dimension? Naja, also da kommen verschiedene Sachen zusammen.
Es kommt natürlich erst mal darauf an, was man überhaupt für eine Frage stellt. Jetzt diese Arbeit, die ich direkt mache mit dieser Analyse von der chemischen Zusammensetzung von Sternen, um daraus zu finden, wann die geboren worden sind und was sie uns über die Elementproduktion im frühen Universum um ganz generell erzählen, da spielt all diese Wettervorhersagen und das alles nicht so eine Rolle, weil die Physik, das ist ja das Coole dabei, die tut einfach ihr Ding, ganz egal wann und wo. Erst wenn man quasi an den Urknall drankommt, dann werden die Bedingungen so extrem, dass auch die normale Physik scheitert. Das ist auch noch mal ein Thema für sich, aber ansonsten ist das erst mal nicht das Problem. Weiterführend, und daran bin ich auch sehr interessiert und das mache ich auch viel, ist natürlich, okay, wie können wir jetzt diese ganzen Sterne überhaupt da verstehen, wie können wir die Wiegen, in denen sie geboren wurden, verstehen, also die kleinen Protogalaxien, und wie ist genau diese Anreicherung da vor sich gegangen mit den Elementen, die da von den Supernovas ins All gesprüht wurden. Da kann ich nur sagen, das ist wirklich manchmal wie Wetter. Wir benutzen natürlich die Gesetze der Physik und wir machen viele, viele Vereinfachungen.
Das muss man natürlich schon sagen, um quasi herauszufinden, wird es morgen warm oder wird es morgen kalt.
Also das können auch die meisten Wettervorherrsagen ganz gut.
Der Teufel sitzt natürlich im Detail und da versuchen wir dann zum Beispiel mit Beobachtungen dann die Sache irgendwie zu verbessern. Und das, naja, beim Wetter geht es auch ähnlich. Da hat man irgendwo einen Thermometer und dann hat das halt ein bisschen andere Temperaturen, dann wird das Modell angeglichen und dann gibt es eine neue Vorhersage. Also schon nicht unähnhnlich. Also ich stelle mir das vor, dass wir ganz viele Himmelskörper im Universum haben, die alle aufeinander wirken, wie so ein großer Billardtisch oder so was in der Richtung. Aber wenn wir uns jetzt zum Beispiel nur auf den Faktor Ort beziehen, also wo die einzelnen Sterne und Planeten sind. Sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel einen Stern entdeckt, der vor 13 Milliarden Jahren entstanden ist. Könnte man denn zum Beispiel heute sagen, wo war dieser Stern vor exakt 13 Milliarden Jahren? Könnte man dann sagen, hindeutend sagen, der war da? Weil ich denke mir, wenn man da heute von heute zurückrechnet und man ist da nur um so eine tausendste Nachkommastelle falsch, dann ist das doch in 13 Milliarden Jahren komplett woanders. Oder kann man das denn zum Beispiel sagen, wo der war? Ja und nein. Also was wir inzwischen ziemlich gut wissen und auch quasi zurückrechnen können, und das mache ich auch ein bisschen mit meiner Gruppe, ist, dass die ältesten Sterne in der Milchstrasse, die sind überhaupt nicht in der Milchstrasse geboren worden, sondern die sind in kleinen Protogalaxien irgendwo im Universum geboren worden. Nein, nicht irgendwo, aber irgendwo in der Nähe von einer etwas grösseren Protogalaxie, aus der dann mal die Milchstrasse wurde. Also im Universum entwickelt sich alles weiter. Wir hatten es ja schon, es ist nicht alles statisch und nicht alle Sterne sind gleich und auch nicht alle Galaxien sind gleich, sondern es entwickelt sich alles.
Und auch die Mehstrasse war mal eine Babygalaxie und hat durch das Auffressen ihrer kleineren unschuldigen Nachbarn die Größe erreicht, die sie heute hat. Und das kann man also ganz gut mit Simulationen verfolgen, weil die Gravitation eine sehr
verlässliche Kraft ist und wir auch den Rest, also sprich irgendwie Gas und Sterne und so auch erstmal außen vor lassen können. Wir können jetzt leider nicht sagen, okay, du Stern warst in genau der kleinen Zwerggalaxie zu dem und dem Zeitpunkt, aber wir können ganz gut inzwischen sagen, dass diese Sterne halt wirklich aus kleineren Systemen kommen, die irgendwann von der Milchstrasse aufgefressen wurden. Also so ist es halt in der Astronomie und auch in vielen anderen Wissenschaften, dass wir das natürlich gerne leider viel präziser hätten, aber wenn wir alle Antworten schon hätten, hätte ich auch keinen Job mehr, also insofern kann ich gut damit leben. Ist das so ein bisschen wie so ein DNA-Test, dass man sich so einen Stern anschaut und dann sieht, ah, da gibt es die und die Elemente und die passen ja ganz gut zu einem anderen Stern da hinten, also müssen die verwandt in Anführungszeichen sein? Manchmal machen wir das, genau. Da gibt es also schon Möglichkeiten, kommt wieder ein bisschen auf die Fragestellung und auch auf die Sterne und so an.
Aber dieses Zuordnen von über die Elementhäufigkeiten ist was, was wir sehr viel machen und das ist auch ganz wichtig. Genau, die kosmischen Gene halt wieder. Aber wie schwer ist es dann, also es klingt eine doofe Frage und klingt auch vielleicht sehr gemein, aber wie schwer ist es dann wirklich, also wenn man jetzt einmal so einen Stern gefunden hat, einmal das weiss, wie das geht, wie schwer ist es dann, noch weitere Stellen zu finden oder ist es einfach, kann man da auch einen Praktikanten dran setzen, wenn man ihm sagt, wie es läuft und oder ist es wirklich, kommt es da wirklich auf Erfahrungswerte an und haben Sie da mittlerweile auch so einen Blick für, wo man mit solchen Sternen rechnen kann? Ja, da kommen ja auch wieder verschiedene Sachen zusammen. Also zum allerersten Mal braucht man Geduld und dann braucht man natürlich auch eine Technik, wo man irgendwie weiß, wie die klappt und welche Aspekte da besonders gut klappen und welche vielleicht weniger gut klappen. Ich habe ja auch als Doktorandin angefangen, selber ohne quasi zu wissen, was ich überhaupt getan habe, da die Sterne zu suchen, weil mir da, also ich hatte, da hatten einige Leute natürlich schon Vorarbeit geleistet und Daten gesammelt und die mussten dann dementsprechend ausgewertet werden und die wussten halt dann schon so ein bisschen, okay, das funktioniert und das funktioniert nicht. Also Erfahrung ist immer hilfreich, aber Fleiss und Geduld sind ebenfalls extrem wichtig. Und wie sieht denn so ein Tagesablauf aus, wenn Sie dann zum Beispiel, wenn Sie dann aktiv suchen nach Sternen? Ich nehme an, dann sind Sie irgendwie in einer Form an so ein Teleskop connected, was den Himmel absucht. Und dann, wie sieht denn so ein Tag aus? Ja, also die Kandidatensuche, die ist leider relativ langweilig, weil das hauptsächlich mit Computerprogrammen geht, die über riesige Datenmengen von irgendwelchen Himmelsdurchmusterungen laufen. Aber ich kann kurz beschreiben, wie das aussieht, wenn man gute Kandidaten gefunden hat und die dann nachbeobachten muss, um dann Daten zu kriegen, mit denen man dann auch diese Häufigkeiten bestimmen kann, um zu sagen, okay, du bist ein Stern, der ist Eisenarm oder bei dir immer falsch gelegen. Und wir fliegen also mehrmals im Jahr nach Chile, nach Südamerika, um dort die Teleskope zu benutzen.
Ganz speziell benutzen wir das Magellan-Teleskop oder es sind sogar zwei Teleskope, aber wir benutzen meistens nur eins. Das hat einen 6,5 Meter grossen Spiegel und da ist so ein schöner Spektrograph dran, mit dem man also diese Spektren, diese Prismenaufnahmen machen kann von den Sternen. Und da muss man halt erst mal 30 Stunden hinfliegen und fahren auf dem Berg mit dem Auto am Schluss, völlig in die Pampa. Und dann trifft man da quasi mitten im Nichts auf ein kleines Dörfchen, wo einige Teleskope am Horizont blitzen und wo es auch so Zimmerchen gibt, wo man dann bleiben kann. Und es gibt auch so einen Speisesaal und man wird da von den Köchen verköstigt, die halten einen ganz gut bei Laune, mit gutem Essen, vor allen Dingen, wenn das Wetter schlecht ist. Aber man macht sich halt nachmittags zum Teleskop auf, da muss man dann verschiedene Kalibrationsmessungen fertig machen. Und dann geht man zum Abendessen wieder runter. Das ist irgendwie nur so fünf Minuten Fahrt mit dem Auto, das geht also alles relativ schnell. Und dann so um den Sonnenuntergang rum macht man sich dann wieder auf ans Teleskop und dann arrangiert man sich da mit dem Teleskop Operator, also da ist jemand, der bedient das Teleskop und als Astronom bedient man die Instrumente und trifft alle
weiteren Entscheidungen. Und wenn es dann wirklich dunkel ist, geht es los und dann ist es eigentlich
wie eine gigantische Digitalkamera. Man hat hat mehrere Bildschirme, man hat alle möglichen Zahlen, auf die man ein Auge werfen sollte. Haben Sie da mal Quatsch gemacht? Haben Sie da mal gesagt, jetzt gucken wir mal irgendwo in so ein Haus, in so ein Fenster rein? Da würde man gar nichts mehr sehen, weil die Auflösung zu gross ist. Das haben Leute mal gemacht, so Sponsoren von dem Teleskop. Also wir gucken gar nicht durch irgendein Okular. Man nimmt mit einem gigantischen Detektor, nimmt man da gigantische Bilder auf von der Pixelzahl her. Aber für so Sponsoren haben die Leute mal so ein Okular da extra eingebaut und das Teleskop mal auf den Mond gerichtet und da hat man eigentlich nur grau gesehen, weil das so reingezoomt war, das war schon gar nicht mehr lustig. Das ist natürlich ein Luxusproblem, aber so naja, irgendwelche fernen Galaxien kann man natürlich schon ganz gut damit angucken.
Aber nee, meistens nicht. Das ist nämlich auch ziemlich teuer.
So eine Nacht kostet 50.000 Dollar.
Also nur die Kosten, also da muss man schon gucken, dass man, wenn man technische Probleme hat,
nicht zu viel darüber nachdenkt, wie jetzt die Dollar da durchrieseln wie im Casino.
Ja, das ist ja ganz schön viel. Also das ist irgendwie ein Dollar pro Sekunde. Aber im Großen und Ganzen sind das jetzt keine grossen Kosten für Forschungsanlagen. Da gibt es andere, die verschlucken wesentlich mehr. Aber es ist trotzdem natürlich viel Geld. Und ich versuche immer deswegen, so wenig Dummheiten wie möglich zu machen, anstattdessen lieber da Photonen aufzusammeln von meinen Sternchen. Genau, also die Informationen, die Sie dann von dem Teleskop konkret bekommen, sind dann Licht mehr oder weniger, also wie ein grosses Foto. Genau, es ist nur Licht. Und dann gucken Sie, ah hier, guck mal, da ist doch was Kleines, lass uns da mal ranzoomen, vereinfacht gesagt. Fast, also zoomen tun wir eh schon, wie es geht. Wir nehmen halt dieses Spektrum auf und also im Prinzip, wenn man sich das Regenbogen, wenn man sich den Regenbogen vorstellt, hat man ja alle Farben einmal da. Und was wir aufnehmen ist der Regenbogen, aber ab und zu fehlen Farben im Regenbogen, also so ein ganz
bisschen von der Farbe. Und das weist uns darauf hin, dass in der Sternatmosphäre, die wir ja
tatsächlich beobachten, bestimmte Elemente vorkommen, die genau bei diesen Farben Licht
absorbieren. Die verschlucken das Licht einfach. Und wir messen dann quasi das, was nicht da ist. Und dann suchen wir noch nach dem Stern, wo möglich wenig nichts da ist, weil das dann darauf hinweist, dass also besonders wenig Eisen oder Kohlenstoff oder Sauerstoff in diesen Sternen da auftaucht. Moment, Sterne haben eine Atmosphäre. Hat die Sonne auch eine Atmosphäre?
Ja, also ein Stern ist natürlich allererstes Mal einfach eine grosse Gaskugel, aber da gibt es auch jede Menge Struktur. Also natürlich in den kleinen Kern, wo die Kernfusion stattfindet, dann kommt erst mal eine relativ grosse, langweilige Kugel da drum. Und dann außen drum ist so eine etwas dünnere Atmosphäre, es gibt da mehrere Schichten quasi. Und das ist das letztendlich, was wir beobachten. Genau, die Sonne hat das Corona, zum Beispiel das Bier, ich will dafür keine Werbung machen, aber es gibt ein Bier, das heißt wie eine äussere Schicht der Sonne. Die sieht man ja bei einer Sonnenfünsternis, kann man die ja ringsherum ganz gut erklären. Genau, genau, da sieht man dann genau, was die Corona da zu bieten hat, weil der Rest, also die Scheibe der Sonne natürlich verdeckt ist. Mir ist gerade eine doofe Frage eingefallen, die ich mir gestellt habe. Ja bitte, die ich immer am gut besten. Ja, weil ich dachte gerade, wenn Sie verschiedene Farben messen, die haben ja verschiedene Wellenlängen, verschiedene Farben. Genau. Aber warum sind die dann genauso schnell? Ich meine, Lichtgeschwindigkeit, klar, es ist eine Konstante und alles Licht ist gleich schnell, immer sehr schnell. Aber warum ist Blau genauso schnell wie Rot, weil wo es doch viel mehr Strecke zurücklegen
muss, weil die Wellenlänge doch eine andere ist. Ah, da kommen wir zu dem schönen Faktum, dass, also es gibt ja bei Licht die Welle-Teilchen-Dualität. Und was wir einsammeln sind Teilchen. Wir sammeln also mit unserem Detektor und auch mit jeder Fotokamera natürlich, wir sammeln Photonen auf. Die schlagen quasi Elektronen aus dem Detektor und dadurch gibt es einen kleinen Strom und so wird das dann letztendlich in ein Bild umgewandelt. umgewandelt. Und was wir dann aber quasi als Bild auf dem Detektor sehen, wird dadurch, dass wir das durch ein Spektrum jagen, komplett aufgesplitten in, oder splitt aufgesplitten, Gott weiß ich gar nicht, wie das auf Deutsch heißt, aufgespalten, ja, ich hab's. Deutsche schwere Sprache, schwere Sprache. Auf jeden Fall. Es wird also aufgespalten im Prisma und dann in die Wellenlängen zerteilt.
Also das eine hat mit dem anderen nicht so viel zu tun. Alles klar, das ist spannend. Weil Wellenlänge, gut, das macht schon Sinn. Das Prisma leitet das eine ins andere um. Kommt es dann auch manchmal vor, dass sie Sterne verlieren, also dass sie sehen, ah, hier gestern irgendwie hier links hat ein bisschen blau gefehlt und dann finden sie den aber nie wieder, weil die Erde dreht sich ja und die drehen sich ja auch alle und dann, woher weiss man denn, wo der am nächsten Tag dann sein wird? Ja, also die Erde dreht sich zwar, aber da wir ja immer wieder nachts beobachten, hilft das. Aber klar, man muss genau strategisch sich überlegen, wie man die ganze Nacht lang die Beobachtungen so hinpuzzelt, dass man genau das beobachten kann, was man will. Was ein wichtigerer Punkt da ist, dass wir uns entweder in der nördlichen oder südlichen Hemisphäre befinden. Das sagt uns, ob wir da so Targets und Kandidaten beobachten können. Und dann natürlich, welche Jahreszeit wir haben. Denn die Bewegung um die Sonne ist dabei viel ausschlaggebender. Also wir sehen jeden Tag nachts wieder das Gleiche am Himmel, aber sechs Monate später tun wir es nicht. Dann gucken wir in eine andere Richtung, weil wir auf der anderen Seite der Sonne sind. Macht es manchmal wahnsinnig, dass Sie Dinge angucken, die so gar nicht mehr existieren? Das ist ja nur das Licht, das ist ja nur so eine Projektion, was wir jetzt halt bekommen, aber das ist ja teilweise Milliarden Jahre alt.
Ja, ja, das ist sogar gar nicht mal ganz richtig, weil das ist ja das Coole bei meinen alten Sternen, die sind ja in unserer Milchstrasse und die Milchstrasse ist gar nicht so gross, dass das Licht so, so, so lange zu uns unterwegs ist, dass die Dinger schon abgestorben sind. Also das Licht von den Sternen, die wir so beobachten, ist mehrere tausend Jahre unterwegs. Okay, also die gibt es alle noch so. Genau, die gibt es noch, weil die Lebensdauer von diesen Sternen 15 Milliarden Jahre ist. Also da brauchen wir uns zum Glück keine Sorgen machen. Aber meine Kollegen, die diese weit entfernten Galaxien beobachten, bei denen ist das natürlich der Fall, dass sie nur noch das Licht kriegen und wir haben überhaupt keine Ahnung mehr, was mit den Objekten inzwischen passiert ist. Das ist schon gruselig, weil da bekommt man immer so ein bisschen Eindruck von der Entfernung überhaupt, die man da spricht. Das ist ja echt beeindruckend immer. Entschuldigung, ich denke gerade über Lichtgeschwindigkeit nach. Warum ist Licht so schnell? Ja, so schnell ist es nur auch wieder nicht.
Also es ist natürlich schon schnell jetzt für Urwurverhältnisse und so,
aber 300.000 Meter pro Sekunde ist jetzt Meter oder Kilometer.
Ich muss mal nachwachen.
Ich glaube, es ist 300.000 Meter. 300.000 Meter pro Sekunde.
Yes, wie gut ist das denn?
Ich habe Sie korrigiert, wie gut ist das denn?
Das ist der beste Tag meines Lebens. Gut aufgefasst, ich habe das nur mal als kleinen Test angebracht. Ich habe mich neulich gefragt, da gab es ja ganz lange diese Diskussion über diesen einen Stern, wo man diese Alien Megastructure vermutet hat. Ja genau, wo bestimmt auch viele Fragen kamen, aber da habe ich mir mal so Gedanken gemacht, angenommen wir würden da hinfliegen, in Lichtgeschwindigkeit, mal rein hypothetisch.
Und das Bild, ich glaube das war 750 Lichtjahre entfernt, sagen wir mal.
Das heißt wir bräuchten 700 Jahre dahin. Und dann macht man mal Stopp nach 350 Lichtjahren, also man ist 350 Jahre hingereist, dann sieht man ja plötzlich das, was da in
350 Jahren passiert. Heißt, sieht man dann, angenommen man beobachtet als Raumschiff, was in
Lichtgeschwindigkeit drauf zufliegt, die ganze Zeit diesen Stern, würde man den dann in doppelter
Geschwindigkeit sehen, was da passiert? Naja, man hat schon den Effekt von relativen
Geschwindigkeiten. Also wenn sich zwei Züge mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit voneinander wegbewegen, dann ist der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Untergrund der Unter Nee, genau. Genauso wäre das auch, wenn wir jetzt auf diesem Planeten da zurasen. Also mal angenommen, der ist statisch und bewegt sich nicht, was natürlich auch nicht ganz geht, weil sich ja alles auch in der Galaxie um das Zentrum der Milchstrasse bewegt. Und dann würden wir ihn halt quasi nur etwas jünger sehen, 350 Jahre jünger. Das wäre alles. Wie sieht man dann den Planeten, wenn man die ganze Zeit den Planeten beobachtet, man fährt in Lichtgeschwindigkeit darauf zu,
würde man dann einfach die Zeit so vergehen sehen, weil man kommt ja irgendwann da bei null an, man ist aber bei minus 750 Jahre gestartet. Also in meinem Kopf müsste man ja schneller sehen, was auf diesem Planeten passiert. Naja, man sieht also, wenn ich mich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit auf ein statisches Objekt zubewege, dann ist das genau das gleiche, wie wenn ich statisch bin und sich das Objekt auf mich zubewegt.
Da kriegt man natürlich dann so Effekte wie Zeitdilatation, also die Zeit verkürzt sich und das alles und man sieht das Objekt dadurch jünger.
Also man kann, man reist quasi zurück in der Zeit.
Das ist wirklich ganz schön beeindruckend.
Es ist klar, es ist natürlich total cool.
Ich habe immer so das Gefühl, wenn ich zu viel darüber nachdenke, dann kriege ich nur ein paar Knoten im Gehirn. Deswegen mache ich es meistens nicht. Und so Einheiten wie Meter und Kilometer oder Jahre und Milliarden von Jahren ist dann irgendwann nur noch Einheiten. Die Einheiten sind doch auch Quatsch, oder? Reden Wissenschaften überhaupt in Einheiten? Also reden sie in Tagen? Weil ich meine, das sind doch alles so menschengemachte Bullshit-Einheiten. Ich meine, im Endeffekt geht es doch eh alles, wir sollten doch eh in Naturkonzernen sprechen, oder? Wir haben schon astronomische Einheiten, die sind im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes astronomisch. Also wir reden eigentlich sonst viel mit Parsec und Kiloparsec. Ein Parsec sind 3,2 Lichtjahre, Kiloparsec dann 3.200. Das ist schon eine handlichere Einheit. Die Galaxienkollegen reden dann von Megaparsecs. Also das wird dann richtig weit. Wir reden immer von Millionen Jahren, Milliarden von Jahren oder Gigajahren. Also da tut man dann immer nur noch das kleine Kürzelchen vorne dran schreiben. Wie Giga oder Millionen oder Milliarden oder sowas. Und da geht das schon, da geht das schon. Da hätte ich auch zu geraten. Das verliert man ja den Überblick. Wie weit kann man denn ins Universum in die Vergangenheit schauen? Also was wäre dann das potenziell am weitesten entfernte Objekt, das man noch sehen kann? Urknall. Kann man den Urknall noch sehen? Das ist das Rauschen nicht, was wir im Fernsehen sehen, der Urknall? Genau, das Rauschen, das ist aber uns quasi entgegengekommen. Weil das ja Wellen sind, die sich bewegen oder Teilchen, die sich auf Wellenformen, förmigen Bahnen bewegen. Ja, also beobachtungsmäßig gibt es natürlich da einiges an Galaxien, die extrem weit weg sind. Und die sind dann also schon 13 Milliarden Lichtjahre weit weg, aber ungefähr so weit ist man da bisher schon gekommen. Man kann sich natürlich überlegen, da haben es nicht so besonders viele Photonen aus der Frühzeit bisher geschafft, aber so eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf schon. Und das kann dann auch mit ganz ausgeklügelten Techniken dann als Galaxie nachgewiesen werden. Aber damit arbeiten Sie ja eigentlich als Astrophysikerin irgendwo so gegen Zeitlimit, weil alles, was vor diesem Punkt war, können sie ja nicht mehr wahrnehmen und können sie ja auch nie wissen. Genau. Das ist ja einfach verloren. Genau, also die Zeit, auf jeden Fall so, wie die wir mit unseren Gehirnen auffassen können, das beginnt alles mit einem Urknall. Was vorher war, das ist für unsere Gehirne nicht so richtig gemacht und auch für unsere Physik nicht. Mit Mathematik kommt man da noch ein bisschen voran, aber das hält sich auch sehr an Grenzen. Ja, das ist eine Grenze, aber in jetzt meinem Fall ist das auch ein Vorteil, weil ich arbeite ja genau an der Grenze quasi, jetzt nicht der Grenze des Universums als solches, also dem Urknall, sondern an dieser Grenze, wann genau war der Zeitpunkt, als das Universum zum ersten Mal beleuchtet wurde. Denn man stellt sich dem Urknall immer irgendwie als was Helles und rot-gelb, also so als Feuer irgendwie vor, mit Farben und so, aber es war natürlich alles total dunkel. Es gab keine Lichtquellen und die ersten Lichtquellen. Haben Sie eine Vorstellung vom Nichts? Weil, haben Sie eine Vorstellung, was davor war? Also einfach nur so, natürlich macht es keinen Sinn, darüber zu reden, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen, auf der einen Seite ist es aber auch spannend, wie jemand, der sich halt tagtäglich auf eine Art damit beschäftigt, nach der Vorstellung zu fragen, weil ich meine, Ich meine, davor, also das, also das ist ja aus dem Nichts entstanden, aber davor war halt auch keine Zeit, also. Genau, genau, ja, es gibt einfach, also ich habe jetzt keine direkte Vorstellung, weil ich mir eigentlich auch keine so richtig machen will, weil alles, was ich mir vorstellen würde, wäre irgendwie falsch. Aber ich habe natürlich ein bisschen ein Gespür dafür, was es bedeutet, wenn physikalische Gesetze zusammenbrechen und wenn auf einmal der Apfel nicht mehr runterfällt. Also das ist, finde ich eigentlich viel lustiger, sich da mal Gedanken darüber zu machen. Was wäre, wenn in irgendeinem unserer physikalischen Gesetze, die das Universum beschreiben, wenn da irgendwo ein bisschen was anders wäre, dann wäre natürlich alles völlig anders. Und ich glaube, der Urknall ist vielleicht einfach ein Extremfall davon. Es ist einfach alles anders. Vor einiger Zeit haben ja grosse wissenschaftliche Schlagzeilen die Runde gemacht, und zwar die Gravitationswellen, die ja glaube ich jetzt bewiesen wurden.
Genau. Auch heute wieder eine neue, eine neue, eine neue Welle. Was ist das genau? Das sind Wellen, die ausgehen vom Urknall und dann sich durchs Universum bewegen? Ich glaube eher von schwarzen Löchern, die aufeinander prallen, oder? Genau, genau. Wen können wir das fragen? Also es gibt auch Ripples, kleine, kleinste Wellen, die ein Überbleibsel vom Urknall sind.
Und da hatten ja auch vor einigen Jahren Leute versucht, das nachzuweisen, aber dann stellte sich raus, die Messungen waren leider doch nicht ganz richtig. Genau, aber das, was jetzt regelmäßig nachgewiesen werden kann, sind diese Wellen von den kollidierenden schwarzen Löchern. Und das ist schon ziemlich cool. Also schwarze Löcher sind sowieso schon mal extrem und auch extrem cool, weil das sind ja quasi Punktmassen, also unendlich kleine Objekte, die aber eine grosse Masse haben. Verstehe ich nicht. Und in den nachgewiesenen Sachen, ja, da darf man auch nicht so genau darüber nachdenken. Es ist so, wie wenn man eine Feder vor sich hat und eine Bleikugel. Die Bleikugel wiegt einfach mehr, oder sagen wir mal ein Styroporkügelchen und ein Bleikügelchen. Das Bleikügelchen wiegt einfach mehr und es sind trotzdem zwei kleine niedliche Kügelchen. Und ein schwarzes Loch ist halt die mega extreme Version der Bleikugel. Und da es gibt, ich hatte ja schon am Anfang mal gesagt, Sterne, die bilden sich nicht so gerne alleine, sondern immer in so Gruppen. Und da kann es halt sein, dass es immer zwei dicke, fette Sterne gibt, die dann beide explodieren und dann bleiben halt zwei schwarze Löcher übrig. Und wenn die sich besonders gerne haben, dann umkreisen die sich. Irgendwann prallen die halt mal zusammen, weil sie sich noch lieber haben. Nee, es wird einfach Energie verloren aus dieser Umkreisung.
Und dann spiralen die so ineinander und dann stossen die zusammen. Und das ist natürlich, also wenn man da so zweimal 20 Sonnenmassen aufeinander knallt, dann kann man sich natürlich gut vorstellen, dass es da ein paar Konsequenzen hat. Und eine Konsequenz ist, dass man die Bildung eines doppelt so schweren Objekts hat. Und laut Einstein ist ja die Raumzeit eine Reflektion der Massen und der Gravitation im Universum. Also man kann sich das wie so ein Gummituch vorstellen. Und wenn man da jetzt einen Basketball reinschmeißt, dann dehnt sich das Gummen so und so viel. Und wenn ich einen Tennisball reinschmeisse, dann dehnt sich es nicht ganz so viel runter. Und wenn ich selbst reinspringe, dann hängt mein Hintern auf dem Fussboden, also das wäre dann quasi das schwarze Loch. Das geht also wirklich bis ganz runter und das ist quasi die Singularität des schwarzen Lochs. Wenn ich jetzt aber meine, wenn ich jetzt zusammen mit meinem Sohn auf das Gummituch springe, dann dehnt es sich natürlich noch mal mehr, weil ich einfach mehr wiege, da muss ich nicht mehr ausgedehnt sein quasi. Naja, lange Rede, gar kein Sinn. Wenn man jetzt so zwei schwarze Löcher hat, die sich da vereinigen, dann macht es quasi einen ordentlichen Bouncer in diesem Gummituch. Aber dann vergeht die Zeit kurz mal anders bei uns, oder? Nee, nee, das passiert einfach da drüben. Und dann wie Wasserwellen, also wie wenn man einen Stein ins Wasser geschmissen hat, dann Vorsicht, und man steht mit den Füssen im Wasser, irgendwann erreichen dann diese konzentrischen Ringe auch meine Füsse. Im Falle meiner Füsse haben jetzt diese Leute halt da ihre riesigen Detektoren, um diese Gravitationswellen aufzufangen. Und wir warten, wir müssen eigentlich nur warten, bis uns diese Wellen, diese konzentrischen Ringe da, bis sie ankommen. Und wie es jetzt so aussieht, scheint die Technik so gut zu funktionieren, dass jetzt regelmäßig da was ankommt.
Wir wissen halt leider manchmal nicht genau, wo es genau herkommt, weil da die Auflösung ist nicht so gut. Aber man kann auf jeden Fall ganz genau sagen, das, was angekommen ist, und man kann aus der Art der Wellen schliessen, was das für zwei Objekte gewesen sind, die sich da vereinigt haben, aufgrund dieses Bouncing in dem Gummituch halt. Also spricht der Unterschied zwischen Basketball und Tennisball. Und wenn so eine Gravitationswelle bei uns ankommt, dann würde das eine schlagartige Erhöhung der Gravitation bedeuten. Nein, nein, nein. Also Gravitation als solche ist einfach erst mal nur die Kraft, die den Apfel auf meinen Zeh fallen lässt. Das ist durch Newtons Gesetz F gleich M, also Masse mal Beschleunigung gegeben. Gravitationswellen sind ein bisschen was anderes. Das sind die Bewegungen und die Verkrümmungen der Raumzeit. Also das ist eine Eigenschaft, die der Raumzeit zu inne liegt. Das ist eine Eigenschaft des Universums, es ist keine Kraft, die im Universum wirkt, aufgrund von, sagen wir mal, einer Anziehungskraft zwischen zwei Objekten im Universum, wie die Erde und die Sonne. Aber je nachdem, wo wir auf dem Tuch sind, also angenommen, wenn wir im Basketball sind oder im Tennisball, ändert sich ja auch was auf uns. Aber wenn jetzt so eine Welle, ich stelle mir so ein Tuch vor, was dann schwingt quasi, weil irgendwo was passiert ist, irgendwo sind zwei Bilderkugeln zusammengeknallt, das Tuch gerät in Wellen und irgendwann springt unsere Erde so hoch.
Hat das dann im krassesten Fall auch eine Auswirkung auf unser Leben oder merken wir das gar nicht? Ne, ne, also wir werden andauernd von Gravitationswellen durchflutet, weil immer irgendwo im Universum gerade da so zwei massive Objekte aufeinandertreffen. treffen, die Masse, was dann auch Gravitation natürlich auslöst und auch auf andere Objekte,
und Gravitation spielt natürlich auch eine riesige Rolle, dass diese zwei schwarzen Löcher überhaupt erst mal da so aufeinander zutreffen. Das spielt dann quasi eine indirekte Rolle, weil die Masse dann die Art dieser kleinen Wellen beeinflusst, aber nicht notwendigerweise die Wellen selber. Also die Wellen kommen aufgrund der Eigenschaften der Raumzeit und die Masse der Objekte, und da kommt die Gravitation zum Spiel, formt dann also die Wellen. Also wie jetzt diese konzentrischen Ringe im Wasser zum Beispiel aussehen werden, ob sie eine hohe Amplitude haben oder eine andere Frequenz oder so. Und genau deswegen kann man das ja dann auch zurückverfolgen. Wir haben auch ein paar Fragen aus der Community bekommen, wo ein paar Hörer uns Fragen geschickt haben. Ich fand eine ganz spannend, die kommt von Möbius und der fragt, was sie sich von dem neuen James Webb Space Teleskop erhoffen, dem JWST, was ja auch, wie ich gelesen habe, so ein paar Neuerungen mitbringt, die viele Leute freuen, was da noch entdeckt werden kann. Was ist da genau die Besonderheit und haben Sie damit was zu tun und was freut Sie daran? Ja, also ganz direkt habe ich selber nichts damit zu tun. Das ist nämlich ein Infrarotteleskop, das wird demnächst ins All geschossen. Ich hoffe, dass es das alles überlebt und dann uns schöne Daten sammeln kann. Das ist der Nachfolge- oder das Nachfolgeteleskop vom Hubble-Weltraumteleskop, was im sichtbaren Bereich beobachtet. Und das liegt mir sehr viel näher. Also ich arbeite lieber mit sichtbarem Licht. Aber was für meine Arbeit von grosser Bedeutung sein wird, sind die Arbeiten, die meine Kollegen mit dem James Webb machen werden, und zwar sind das die sehr weit entfernten Galaxien. Also das ist mit Absicht ein Infrarotteleskop geworden, damit man hoch-, also sehr weit entfernte Galaxien beobachten kann, weil die kann man besonders gut im Infrarotlicht beobachten, weil aufgrund der grossen Entfernung die Wellenlänge des Lichts also grösser geworden ist.
Die Geschwindigkeit hat sich nicht verlangsamt, aber die Wellen werden länger, deswegen ein Infrarotteleskop.
Es wird vorhergesagt, dass da neue Rekorde gebrochen werden können, weil die Qualität des Teleskops so gut sein wird. Man muss das natürlich abwarten und gucken, aber ich hoffe sehr, dass es quasi so Counterparts geben wird, also dass Galaxien entdeckt werden können, ich muss ein bisschen ernst rum sagen,
also wir hatten es ja schon, dass die altesten Sterne in der Milchstrasse, nicht in der Milchstrasse selber geboren wurden,
sondern in kleinen Protogalaxien, in kleinen Babygalaxien.
Und ich hoffe, dass das James-Webb-Space-Teleskop also diese Babygalaxien auch mal direkt beobachten kann.
Und das wäre natürlich absolut fantastisch, wenn wir da quasi zu den gleichen Ergebnissen kommen. Wenn es jetzt so ein neues Teleskop gibt, sind denn die Daten, die dieses Teleskop sammelt, einfach öffentlich? Kann da jeder darauf zugreifen oder muss man die kaufen? Oder gibt es behältes Institut, das dieses Teleskop hat, dann für die für sich oder wie läuft das? normaler der normale prozess ist dass sich astronomen im wettbewerb auf zeit bewerben können man muss dann einen antrag schreiben der ist irgendwo zwischen fünf und zehn seiten lang wo man genau auslegen muss was man machen möchte und was man erwartet und dann wie viel zeit das mit dem teleskop kostet da gibt es dann dann diverse Komitees, die dann letztendlich entscheiden, welcher die coolsten
Projekte hat, denn es gibt immer viel, viel, viel mehr Anfragen, ungefähr mindestens zehnmal so viele
Anfragen auf Zeit, wie es eigentlich Zeit gibt.
Und das ist halt, das heißt, es ist also relativ schwierig, auch für normale Astronomen da Zeit zu kriegen. Die Daten sind dann meist nicht öffentlich zugänglich für ungefähr ein Jahr, so dass dann auch die Autoren, die diese Studie vorgeschlagen haben, dann auch erst mal die Daten für sich selber auswerten können. Meistens werden die Daten dann freigegeben. Also die meisten Daten, die das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop aufgenommen hat, die kann man über verschiedene Webarchive kann sich jeder die runterladen. Was mich interessieren würde, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass Ihre Arbeit sehr auf viele Vorrechnungen, Vorarbeit beruht. Wann wurden Sie das letzte Mal so richtig überrascht? Also wann gab es mal wieder so ein Element der heftigen Überraschung? Weil ich denke, wenn Sie so ein, Sie haben auch gesagt, dann gibt es halt Vorauswertungen und dann sucht man nach Sternen, weiß dann aber auch schon, okay, die existieren da, wir vermuten, die sind sehr alt. Was war so die grösste Überraschung in der letzten Zeit? Also 2016 haben wir ja eine Studie veröffentlicht, wo wir eine kleine Zwerggalaxie untersucht hatten. Und die ist voll mit schweren Elementen und wir wussten überhaupt nicht, dass es das überhaupt gibt. Und als mein Student damals am Teleskop war und ich zu Hause, rief er er mich um zwei Uhr morgens an und sagte, ach na, ich glaube, ich habe was falsch gemacht. Da ist so eine komische Linie im Spektrum, die gehört da nicht hin. Und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, na ja, hast du das und das und das alles gemacht mit den Aufnahmen und so, ja, ja, ja. Dann hat er mir da so einen Graph geschickt, dann habe ich mir das auch mal angeguckt.
Und dann habe ich so ein kleines Wittchen gemacht, da habe ich gesagt, naja, das ist wahrscheinlich so eine Erbprozessgalaxie, also eine Galaxie, die einfach voll ist mit diesen schweren Elementen aus dem unteren Teil des Periodensystems, die man nur auf sehr komplizierte Art und Weise überhaupt herstellen kann. Und ich glaube zwei, drei Stunden später rief er mich wieder an und sagte, Anna, ich habe noch einen Stern beobachtet und der sieht genau so aus. Wahnsinn. Und wie sich dann später herausstellte, also sieben andere Sterne sahen auch noch so aus, hatten wir tatsächlich eine Zwerggalaxie gefunden, die voll mit Gold ist. Wow. Oh, die Sche... Ja, einfach Pacht. kann man das besitzen? Können Sie das besitzen? Nee, Himmelskörper dürfen nicht besitzen werden. Also doch. Ja, nicht ganz. Also diese Galaxie ist voll mit diesen schweren Elementen Silber, Gold, Platinum und alles. Hinter. Ich hatte, also wir wussten gar nicht, dass es so eine Galaxie gibt. Und ich hatte da so ein Witzchen gemacht, weil ich gerne auch mal ein Witzchen mache, auch um so, er war so besorgt und da dachte ich, naja, du musst mal ein bisschen die Stimmung auflockern und um zwei Uhr morgens schlafen und dann hat sich das aber herausgestellt und das war natürlich einfach mega cool. Also auch dieser letzte Schritt, also die Sterne erstmal zu finden, ist natürlich ein wichtiger, aber dann sich genau diese Elementhäufigkeiten anzugucken, um dann daraus auch zu lernen über die Ursprünge der aller einzelnen Elemente, da passieren schon ab und zu einfach noch Überraschungen. Was heißt denn, dass die Planeten da einfach andauernd Gold haben, sehr viel Gold und wahrscheinlich Gold bei denen gar nichts wert ist, weil alles voll ist? Wahrscheinlich, ja, genau, die haben ein bisschen zu viel abgekriegt. Wie crazy, das ist schon heftig. Da ist Eisen wahrscheinlich mehr wert. Ja, kann gut sein, warum nicht. Was sind dann so die nächsten Schritte, also was glauben Sie ist so die nächste grosse Neuigkeit, so die uns Öffentlichkeit, also die Gravitationswellen waren halt eine grosse News, was ist so das nächste, oder was könnte so der nächste Durchbruch sein, ist es dann wirklich irgendwie der nächste bewohnbare Planet oder wirklich mal eine Lebensform auf dem Mars oder was auch immer? Ja, also Lebensformen auf dem Mars glaube ich erstmal nicht, aber die Suche nach erdähnlichen Planeten, die ist natürlich, läuft in vollen Zügen und ich denke, da sind wir relativ nah dran. Also, und erdähnlich heisst natürlich nicht ident nicht identisch zur Erde und das heißt lange noch nicht, dass da Leben auch drauf ist.
Aber es ist natürlich ein erster wichtiger Schritt, um diese Frage dann zu beantworten. Was ich sehr spannend auch finde, das ist jetzt schon ein, zwei Jahre alt, aber dass er, also diese neuesten, größeren Studien zeigen, dass ich glaube, jeder zweite Stern mindestens einen Planet hat, Planeten hat im Universum. Also das ist, also ich bin noch aufgewachsen, ich bin noch, in der In der ich noch gelernt, ah, das Universum ist 15 bis 20 Milliarden Jahre alt und nicht 14 oder 13. Und Planeten gibt es im Sonnensystem und damit hat sich's. Ja, und Pluto, guter und Pluto gibt es. Ja, und Pluto gab es auch noch, genau. Man sieht auch noch beteiligt, diese Entscheidung, die können wir bis heute nicht nachvollziehen. Wir hissen auch unsere Pluto-Flaggen, aber irgendwie hat es nicht geschafft, er hat es nicht gepackt. Ja, das ist okay, das ist okay. Aber da hat sich natürlich schon wirklich einiges fundamental geändert. Also sowohl, dass wir das Alter des Universums wissen, als auch, dass jeder zweite Stern, mindestens einen Planet hat.
Also dann gibt es so viele Planeten wie Sterne. Das ist wirklich eine ganze Menge. Und ich sage immer, ich kann nicht ausschliessen, dass es irgendwo Leben gibt, aber die Chancen dafür oder irgendwelche Amöben oder was auch immer steigen natürlich einfach mit der Anzahl von Planeten. Und ich denke, da wird es in den nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahren sicher einige spannende Ergebnisse geben. Ansonsten, ja, also das James-Webb-Teleskop wird natürlich da hoffentlich die ersten oder einige der ersten Galaxien uns bescheren und alles weitere müssen wir mal gucken. Das ist ja auch ganz gut, dass man nicht immer die Zukunft vorhersagen kann, selbst wenn wir als Astronomen gerne in die Vergangenheit blicken. Dann noch eine Frage aus der Community von Robert, der sagt, auf der Erde sagt man, dass ca. 80 % der Weltmeere noch unerforscht sind. Was würden Sie sagen, wie viel Prozent des Universums nach Ihrer Meinung nach unerforscht, beziehungsweise erklärbar ist? Oh, ein wichtiger Unterschied. Also erklärbar würde ich sagen, im Großen und Ganzen sind wir da schon relativ weit.
Also wir können zwar die dunkle Materie und die dunkle Energie nicht direkt beweisen, aber wir können nachweisen, dass es so etwas gibt. Wir haben dem dementsprechend komische Namen gegeben, wie dunkle Energie und dunkle Materie. Aber das kann man schon nachweisen, dass solche Sachen da wirken. Also da würde ich mal sagen, wir haben schon, jetzt das so mit einer Prozentzahl anzugeben, ist natürlich schwierig, aber ich würde mal sagen, weit mehr als die Hälfte unter Kontrolle. Jetzt so direkt quasi beobachtet und nachgewiesen und mal reingeguckt, extrem wenig, also ein paar Prozent. Das sind ja nur vier Prozent des Universums, ist ja überhaupt leuchtende Materie wie Sterne und Gas und Galaxien und Planeten und das ganze Zeug, was für uns wichtig ist. Der Rest ist ja einfach wahrscheinlich nur hohle Energie sozusagen.
Also da sind wir quasi am einen Ende des uns wichtig ist. Der Rest ist ja einfach wahrscheinlich nur hohle Energie sozusagen.
Also da sind wir quasi am einen Ende des Spektrums und mit unserem groben Verständnis sind wir eher am
anderen Ende des Spektrums. Ich habe noch eine Frage und zwar, was mich immer interessiert hat, ist wie die
Temperatur des Universums. Also so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist ja Temperatur einfach nur die
Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich die Teilchen innerhalb von einer Volumeneinheit zum Beispiel bewegen.
Aber so wie ich das verstanden habe, gibt es ja im Großteil des Universums einfach gar nichts.
Also da gibt es ja keine Teilchen, nichts, was sich bewegen könnte. Welche Temperatur hat denn da, wie würde sich das anfühlen?
Naja, also das Universum ist natürlich das beste Vakuum, das kann man nicht mit einem Vakuum auf der Erde vergleichen,
aber dennoch ist es nicht komplett leer, es ist nur sehr teilchenarm. Also es gibt nur ein paar Teilchen pro Kubikmeter, trotzdem ist es nicht komplett leer. Die kosmische Hintergrundstrahlung ist ja eine Reflexion dessen und die sagt, dass das Universum 2,7 Grad Kelvin warm ist, also minus 271 Grad Celsius, minus 273 ist ja der absolute Nullpunkt, da wären dann wirklich keine Teilchen mehr, aber diese drei Teilchen, Tick, Tick und Track von Donald Duck und sow., die machen uns diese 2,7 Grad Kelvin warm. Und wenn wir jetzt einen theoretischen Raum hätten, in dem wirklich gar keine Teilchen sind, also ein ultimatives Vakuum, dann hätte das 0 Kelvin als Temperatur. Genau. Warum das denn? Ja, da bewegt sich einfach nichts mehr. Was soll das sein? Das ist absoluter Stillstand dann. Genau, da ist einfach nichts mehr. Da bleibt dann nur noch die sogenannte Vakuumenergie übrig. Also das ist wahrscheinlich oder eventuell das, was wir als dunkle Energie bezeichnen, eine Art Energiezustand des Raums. Und das wäre dann das, was in so einem absoluten Vakuum übrig bleibt. Aber leider fehlt uns da noch die Einsicht, was das genau ist und wie man das genau beschreiben kann. Und vor allen Dingen natürlich auch, wo es herkommt und warum es überhaupt existiert. Also da haben wir noch ein bisschen was zu tun, aber sonst wäre es ja auch langweilig. Ich glaube, es fällt mir einfach schwer, mir eine Temperatur ohne Medium vorzustellen, also eine Temperatur ohne etwas, das diese Temperatur hat. Aber gut, ist ja auch Weltraum, also wäre langweilig, wenn das alles so einfach zu tun wäre. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich habe noch eine Frage und zwar stelle ich mir, also wir haben sie oft betitelt als der schlauste Mensch der Welt oder der schlauste Mensch, mit dem wir jemals gesprochen haben. Ach Gott. Deswegen mal so eine Frage einfach für uns normalos. Was ist das Dümmste, was sie in letzter Zeit gemacht haben? Einfach so eine dusselige, ich vergesse oft meinen Schlüssel, denk mir, du bist einfach ein Vollidiot. Ja, meinen Schlüssel vergesse ich regelmäßig. Gut, aber manchmal denke ich auch so über was nach und denke so, das wirst du niemals verstehen. Ich habe kein Mikrofon, keine Ahnung, wie das gerade funktioniert, wie wir uns überhaupt hören können. Manchmal denke ich, das ist ziemlich doof, man sollte das wissen als gebildeter Mensch. Aber was ist so das Dümmste, was in letzter Zeit passiert ist? Ein Gedanke, der Ihnen nicht eingefallen ist, irgendwas, auf was Sie nicht gekommen sind? Na ja, da kann ich nur sagen, dass, also ich bin eine alleinerziehende Mutter von einem Dreijährigen und ich schlafe so wenig, ich bin eigentlich dümmer als alle anderen zusammen, weil ich aufgrund meines Schlafmangels mir überhaupt nichts mehr merken kann.
Und es gibt natürlich auch für mich wahnsinnig viele Sachen, die ich überhaupt nicht verstehe.
Und ich verstehe eigentlich auch nur ein bisschen von dem, was ich mache, weil ich halt schon ein paar Jährchen, also sprich fast fünfzehn Jahre damit zugebracht habe, mich da in die Materie einzuarbeiten. Dumm und schlau ist wirklich ein ganz komisches Konzept eigentlich. Jeder, der sich in irgendwas mal eingearbeitet hat, der versteht von seiner Sache was und der ist ziemlich schlau, wenn es um diese Sache geht. Und alle anderen sind ziemlich doof. Und das betrifft mich natürlich genauso wie alle anderen auf diesem Planeten. Und ja, also wenn ich zweimal hintereinander am Tag oder an zwei nacheinander folgende Tagen meinen Schlüssel vergesse, weil ich mit dem Fahrrad ins Büro fahre und dann vor verschlossener Tür stehe und dann erstmal gucken muss, ob mir irgendjemand anders die Tür aufmachen kann. Das ist so beruhigend, dass man Sterne finden kann, aber nicht seinen Schlüssel. Genau. Naja, für Sterne finden hat man ja auch den Computer, der hilft noch. Da muss man zwar manchmal auch ein paar zündende Ideen haben, und die habe ich auch meistens, wenn ich mal unter der Dusche stehe und mal fünf wo gerade sein lassen kann, da finde ich, habe ich immer die besten Ideen, aber alles andere im Leben ist für mich genau die gleiche Herausforderung wie für alle anderen auch, und das ist ja auch gut so. Eine Frage habe ich noch und zwar, so wie ich das verstehe, ist es ja oft so, glaube ich, in der Physik, dass es erst eine gewisse Theorie gibt und die relativ plausibel ist und dann sammelt man Daten und irgendwann sagt man, ja passt, so jetzt wie das Higgs-Boson zum Beispiel, wo ja die Idee schon lange bekannt war und irgendwann gibt es dann halt das Experiment, wo man sagt, gut, Haken dahinter passt. Haben Sie denn auch irgendeine Theorie, wo man sagt, wo Sie sagen, ich glaube, das ist so oder so die Frebel-Theorie, dass wenn die stimmt, dann kriegen Sie einen Nobelpreis oder arbeiten Sie da anders? Also auf den Nobelpreis arbeite ich nicht so direkt hin. Ich habe natürlich, also da gibt es quasi zwei Antworten für. Ich habe natürlich gewisse Ideen, die ich da manchmal unter der Dusche kriege und die ich dann versuche, mit Daten irgendwie zu belegen, um zu gucken, geht das in die richtige Richtung oder nicht. Das sind aber eigentlich meistens eher so, naja, ich würde sagen so Bilder und ich muss mir das Universum irgendwie vorstellen und das klappt bei mir meistens irgendwie mit Farbe und mit Bildern und lauter Sternen und Punkten und Teilchen und allem, was dazugehört, wie so ein Theaterspiel quasi. Dann gibt es natürlich auch noch, habe ich viele Kollegen, die also richtig Theorie machen und dann Computersimulationen aufgrund von den physikalischen Gesetzen laufen lassen. Und das muss natürlich dann auch mit Daten verglichen werden. Und ich arbeite auch mit denen zusammen. Und da hatten wir auch schon eine nette kleine Theorie quasi. Da ging es um das Kühlen, die ausreichende Kühlung in einer Gaswolke, um dann Sterne entstehen zu lassen, denn wir hatten es ja ganz am Anfang, Sterne entstehen aus dem Gas, aber das klappt nicht einfach mal so, holler die Polter, sondern das muss kalt werden. Und es sieht so aus, als Kohlenstoff kann helfen, die Gaswolke zu kühlen.
Und ich habe dann die Beobachtung zusammengetragen und wir haben stundenlang zusammengesessen und das diskutiert.
Und dann sind wir am Schluss mit so einem... kann helfen, die Gaswolke zu kühlen. Und ich habe dann die Beobachtung zusammengetragen und wir haben stundenlang zusammengesessen und das diskutiert.
Und dann sind wir am Schluss mit so einer Grafik angekommen, die dann gezeigt hat,
okay, tatsächlich, die meisten dieser aller eisenärmsten Sterne sind kohlenstoffreich, relativ kohlenstoffreich.
Und das haut genau wie Faust aufs Auge mit dieser Theorie hin,
dass also Kohlenstoff da überhaupt die Entstehung dieser Sterne erst mal zugelassen hat. Also das machen wir schon regelmäßig. Manchmal klappt es besser und manchmal klappt es weniger. Aber letztendlich ist eine Theorie immer nur eine Idee. Und ich habe hunderttausend Ideen, von denen neunhundert neunneunneunneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundneunundnehundert, neunneunhundert neunneunneunzig Schrott sind, aber ab und zu haut dann doch einmal eine hin. Ist das denn so ein bisschen wie Kondensation, wo ja auch Gas, wenn es zu kalt wird, dann irgendwann zu Wasser wird? Ist das auch so wie Sterne entstehen? So ähnlich, so ähnlich, genau. Und die Kühlung, da kann dann so Sachen so klumpen quasi und dann so ähnlich wie eine Kondensation. Ja, ja, genau. Und das geht auch erst mal über Wasser oder über was Flüssiges? Nee, also Gaspartikel, also einfach eine Gaswolke besteht aus Gasteil, also aus Atomen, also aus Teilchen. und die müssen halt irgendwie zusammenschleben.
Also es ist nichts Flüssiges. Und das passiert halt aufgrund der Gravitation, wenn es kalt genug ist. Also das geht direkt von Gas zu Feststoff und nicht so wie jetzt bei Kondensation, erst mal über Wasser. Ja, genau. Es gibt da also nicht verschiedene Aggregatzustände, weil alles natürlich viel zu heiß ist. Also Sternentstehung ist noch mal ein bisschen komplizierter, aber man muss quasi erst mal so kleine Staubkörnchen zusammenkleben lassen.
Und dann, wenn man mal eins hat, dann kleben sich da gerne auch andere Teilchen noch dran und dann wächst da ganz langsam so ein Kern halt.
Und dann kann immer mehr Gas, also Teilchen, Gasteilchen, die halten sich auch so ähnlich wie eine Flüssigkeit, aber es ist keine Flüssigkeit, das kann dann auf diesen, auf so einen Kern drauf spiralen und dann dem richtig dann Masse zukommen lassen, wo dann irgendwann dann mal ein Stern draus wird. Das ist echt spannend alles. Also am Ende wird eigentlich alles zusammengedrückt, so wenn so Sachen nah zusammenkommen, wenn man die ganz fest zusammendrückt, dann wird es einklumpen und dann kommt immer mehr und dann mehr Masse. Masse zieht sich an. Genau, Gravitation. Am Ende ist es Gravitation. Drucken und ziehen. Beide. Fragen nachts, vielleicht rufe ich sie dann einfach nochmal an, falls noch irgendwas offen bleibt. Oder falls wir Ideen haben, wie irgendwie das Universum funktioniert. Ja, hier sind so ein paar Ideen in Schublade. Vielleicht können wir helfen. Genau, genau. Ja, hat mich gefreut, war lustig. Cool. Freut uns sehr. Immer wieder gut, mal über das Universum zu sprechen. Das ist doch schön. Ja, freut uns sehr und ich glaube, wir haben vielleicht auch ein paar Leute da draußen Lust auf Physik machen können. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube schon. Am Ende. Ja, gerne. Ich bin ja auch auf Twitter, ne? Ja, genau, richtig. Kann man sich immer erreichen. Ja, addannafrebel, glaube ich, könnt ihr alle folgen über heisse News aus der Wissenschaft. Genau, genau. Und ansonsten kleine Werbung, ich habe ja auch ein Buch geschrieben über die Suche nach den ältesten Sternen. Da kann man das auch nochmal alles nachlesen. Ja, perfekt. Supercool. Schaut euch das Buch mal an und schaut mal auf Twitter vorbei, wenn euch interessiert hat, was wir jetzt gehört haben. Ich fand es extrem
interessant. Ich finde es auch unfassbar spannend. Und es ist immer
wieder Horizont erweitern, wenn man über diese
unfassbaren Dimensionen spricht. Vielen Dank,
dass Sie gekommen sind. Und viel Erfolg auch weiterhin.
Sie machen das schon.
Sie werden das schon rocken,
wie man wahrscheinlich sagt. Na klar,
ich sage Bescheid, wenn wir
was Neues gefunden haben. Ja, super gern.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank und dann noch einen schönen Tag.
Schönen Tag noch. Tschüss.
Ja, danke schön. Tschüss.